[Music]
but isn't that crazy that there's just
like one pair of sweatpants or your
cPanel but you can't let go of your
choice dick shorts are so good member my
dick shorts and on the beach and I would
worry them in Miami yeah and little kids
could see your pubes and your friends
rock balls and my friends yeah well they
were white right they're like wait no
that was in drdr and that was full see
through a full see-through panties and
full see-through white so you can see
outlines we stated this resort and the
Dominican Republic went for my like 36
birthday and there was a table with
hardcore pornography 24/7 24 yeah was
channel 69 it was yeah and we go to the
bar and eventually you make friends with
the with a bunch of dads remember and we
were all talking these dad boners and we
were like hey what's up with channel 69
and they're like what yeah you don't get
well you don't get hardcore porn I it
was scrambles in their rooms but yeah
well we just see what it was but we
can't watch it we go no we got in our
room oh by the way I never really told
you how much I restrained myself that
weekend from watching that the entire
time because every time I put it on you
were like all right and I was like oh ha
ha ha ha but that's all I was trying to
watch it every time you did not restrain
your of course I'm watching it we were
both watching it no but I wanted to keep
watching it I wanted to keep watching it
every time you went to the bathroom or
took a shower I would watch it it's on
your TV with all your teeth we're so
used to like your phone or your computer
but special its special on your damage
it's like imagine going to a movie
theater and getting to watch it like it
back in the 70s because he can't Theatre
in the yeah that would be especially
that's in business I'd like to open
again
yeah public pornography bad business
models guys right yeah ok next in every
row it's great
remember to on the cruise we went on the
last cruise that they had pornography
but it was too soft yeah
had to call and come on I did and
there's a Filipino guy he goes oh I want
it hardcore he goes hold on a second sir
closes no I talked to the manager and
yeah no we don't have that yeah I don't
want to pay for this thing's like okay